so i've got a clip here i want to get
some um commentary back from uh tim and
paul on this one it's uh retired us army
colonel douglas mcgregor uh he went on
the news and he told the truth about
what led up to the russia ukraine
conflict and why it happened so let me
just throw this up on the screen let me
know if you guys can't hear this
just hit play here and here is colonel
doug mcgregor
former senior advisor to the secretary
of defense thank you for
joining us why do you think putin is
doing this what is his end game
well vladimir putin is carrying through
on something that he's been warning us
about at least for the last 15 years
which is that he will not tolerate u.s
forces or their missiles on his borders
much as we would not tolerate russian
troops and missiles in cuba
and we ignored him and he finally acted
he was not going to allow ukraine under
any circumstances to join nato
what's happened now is that the battle
in eastern ukraine is really almost over
all the ukrainian troops there have been
largely surrounded and cut off you have
a concentration down in the southeast of
30 to 40 000 of them and if they don't
surrender within the next 24 hours i
suspect that the russians will
ultimately annihilate them that's why
zielinski is meeting with
putin's representatives right now the
game is over
and he's going to have to negotiate the
best deal he can get and we've already
told him the president of the united
states has that if he opts for
neutrality for ukraine we'll back him
and i think that vladimir putin will do
that for western ukraine
that is the ukraine beyond the emperor
river but behind it in the east where he
is now i'm not sure what he has planned
there whether he forms another republic
and nexus it into russia because
historically it has been russian but the
territory west of ukraine is not he
knows that and he's happy to live with
that as a neutral state
i am not a military expert i'm not even
an expert on geography but if he takes
ukraine and ukraine abuts poland then
he's going to have a nato country
abutting him so if that's what he
doesn't want then isn't he going to just
have to keep going until he runs out of
nato countries
i i guess i should say it again uh he
has no interest in crossing the west the
damper and heading west to the polish
border
so
tim like what are your thoughts on that
clip yeah that's what i was saying at
the beginning whatever it's like if he'd
stop through the eastern states one of
the things we have to and i think that's
what you want to do stop at the eastern
states uh just just i'm just gonna take
those i'm gonna annex these things i'm
happy the thing about it is um i mean
the monroe doctrine when was that going
back to you now as after the second
world war that's what prevented uh
that's what the cube missile crisis was
about wasn't it it was stopping if i
remember correctly here and i don't get
me wrong i could be it could be
inaccurate but that was stopping um
anyone putting any uh missile systems or
anything on western territory in effect
that's what monroe doctrine said and of
course
i'm not saying
we we tend to be holier than now don't
we in the west thinking that we're not
ever the aggressor we're always right
yeah right
just like with being economically
aggressive is still aggressive
if not more so when people still die
it's not blown apart they're just like
not fed and you know this kind of thing
you know
most horrible debt so um you're
absolutely right and i think if you have
to look at ukraine as well as being the
bread basket of europe i mean the
mineral wealth that country is
staggering i mean the oil and gas there
and everything else is huge yes i'm not
saying that's a thing that he's wanting
we've already discussed about the
population loss and everything else that
he had but it's a very valuable country
and of course all these i'm not even see
i'll tell you the whole thing about this
i find quite interesting you become
almost like um
like a putin apologist by accident and
we're not we're just trying to be
rational about it we're just trying to
say look if you're going to be the
aggressor the whole time you're going to
get it's like in the playground you walk
around punch people in the face some at
some point someone's going to punch you
back if you take it from the russian
perspective when you look at syria and
libya and you look at iraq and you you
literally sit back there and i know he
was supportive in certain actions within
those those um
those conflicts you know we stepped i
remember when i was stepping into iraq
for the i only went in on the 2003-2007
bit
and i remember we had a lawyer come to
the
we're operating on an old year in
mandate and the lawyer came to the
squadron and said if you drop any
weapons and i never did i'm very
fortunate i didn't talk many people to
do that but i never did it myself if you
do drop
your actions are indefensible currently
under the mandate we have and that's
what we were told before we went out
there one of the first ones in iraq i
mean how hospital is that as an
aggressive actress to go into these
countries and to think that we know
better than they do
yeah
well yeah so it means that that
assessment's pretty good because
he does want to restore old borders
because of natural geographical like the
river for example if you start looking
at where the old borders were there were
natural uh geographical um
uh you know defense mechanisms body of
water you know some you know elevation
or whatever mountain type thing like
whatever and i'm not really great on the
geography but if you start going through
it that's what you'll see and the new
borders leave basically open territory
that they don't have the resources or
manpower to protect
and so that's that's part of it and then
yeah it's it's he's saying
i don't want missiles
but we're not necessarily
pushing to do that
it's it's again goes back to
if he the way that they view the world
is
these guys are
economically aggressive and we're a poor
country because of them
and therefore we need to use military
leverage in order to negotiate these
things you know they need to have
negotiating power with the prices of
their resources because of that they
don't understand they don't think like
we do as capitalists which is
okay let's let's let's let free market
diversify an economy so we're not just
trading two things you know what i mean
let's let's let's work trade deals and
let's have a diverse economy because
that's how you climb out of a financial
hole they don't see it that way
in case of point is the government runs
their two
their companies the major companies the
government just runs it so they're not
they don't they don't understand free
market free enterprise or at least they
don't respect it like we do because the
people in power
benefit from not having it that way to a
degree right because they take that
money and so they're not understanding
like well we can get out of
economic poverty this way and be better
trade partners the way that their
ideology is well we need to they're
thinking just in terms of force and
territory and land space and people you
know and and and then
hey we can just say ukrainian
sovereignty really doesn't exist
that we'll make that up now even though
of course obviously the ukrainian are
very motivated to not be owned by russia
but that they'll just say that that's
part of the campaign and try to move
those borders back fight for something
called indivisibility of security which
means that you know we keep things even
and we don't put weapons on each other's
borders and and to halt nato because
nato expansion means they lose military
leverage which means then they lose
the any kind of economic leverage that
they have which isn't very much
that makes sense yeah yeah um here let
me get these super chats and i got
another clip i want to get some feedback
from you guys on uh competent man's
talking about article five mutual
defense yeah um so we covered that
uh
revenge imperialism that's what it is
steve says just looking to get the band
back together again
part of it yeah
uh 22 ruski's reunion to our shirt on
sale here
uh okay so i've got it i've got this
other clip here and i think this guy's
an analyst or a professor if i'm not
mistaken let me just throw it up on the
screen this is uh from march 1st so some
of this stuff is slightly dated but
again uh tell me if you guys can't hear
this i can switch over but uh
which one is this here in my tabs
this guy okay here we go
yeah but i actually think that what's
going on here is that the west is
leading by the way i think this clip
here is from 2014-15 yeah it's back from
that ukraine down the primrose path and
the end result is that ukraine is going
to get wrecked
and i believe that the policy that i'm
advocating which is neutralizing ukraine
and then building it up economically and
getting it out of the competition
between russia on one side and nato on
the other side is the best thing that
could happen to the ukrainians
what we're doing is encouraging the
ukrainians to play tough with the
russians
we're encouraging the ukrainians to
think that they will ultimately become
part of the west because we will
ultimately defeat putin and we will
ultimately get our way time is on our
side
and of course the ukrainians are playing
along with this and the ukrainians are
almost completely unwilling to
compromise with the russians and instead
want to pursue a hardline policy
well as i said to you before if they do
that the end result is that their
country is going to be wrecked and what
we're doing is in effect encouraging
that outcome
i think it would make much more sense
for us to neutral to work to create a
neutral ukraine it would be in our
interest to bury this crisis as quickly
as possible it certainly would be in
russia's interest to do so and most
importantly it would be in ukraine's
interest to put an end to the crisis
thank you
thoughts on that tim
yeah he's um his actual speech is about
an hour 40 no alford our 15 minutes long
it's worth watching the whole thing
um he's kind of there's a couple of
experts that have come out obviously
three experts are here right you know we
could just be guys around the chicken
wing bar couldn't we being experts and
stuff with it with a few beers but um
there's other experts apparently that
have studied their whole life who reckon
they know better than us
but yeah
yeah
um probably a lot more fun but uh yeah
so that guy is worth watching him and i
can't remember his name uh he's a he's a
pretty decent dude pretty worth finding
out rachel put a link in in the
description here because he does explain
how the west kind of led
to this really and i can kind of see
that oh it's interesting as well and i
know we're going to probably get on to
at some point rich but
the the weakness or the perceived
weakness of someone like
received weakness of the west by someone
like putin of course who is trying to
restore the ussr to pre kind of uh
yeltsin days and and that's going back i
think he's always hung up on the fact
that the strength he felt there's a
superpower wasn't it when his u.s side
was only two super powers in the world
of which he was one and now he's not
really a superpower either by gdp or
anything else or military might it's
embarrassing for him what's happening
right now of course but it hasn't just
happened very quickly and he hasn't been
a blitch creep and he's in kiev and he's
still in power that hasn't happened i
think he's very um
an ego like that is very he's very
delicate and very wounded you know the
west is very good at promising people as
paul was saying earlier a lot of things
and then and they're not delivering
things happen we have governments that
last for three years for example how
long's putin being in power for now i
have to go back and and try and work
that one out this is one of the longest
standing people in power i think there's
a there's a video clip somewhere of him
with every american president for like
since george bush i think one or two
yeah must have been yeah yeah there's
media wasn't he swapped positions of
media didn't then swap back again after
he changed the constitution to allow him
to stay in further so he has been part
of that infrastructure suppose he helps
him for many many years and of course uh
a guy like that who feels he is probably
you know the father of russian is
rebuilding it in the image the czarist
imperialism as it probably used to be he
has talked about that in the past of
course quite quite considerably you can
understand that um
for him it doesn't seem like he's doing
anything aggressive he's just trying to
re-establishing the borders that worked
when the country was great and uh
and of course
it's almost i kind of it's kind of it's
almost understanding for a historian i
think david starkey was something saying
something very similar to this the
british historian we had was saying
something very similar it's
understandable
just for us wrapped up in our very
short-term western ways
we see it as a supreme act of regression
against the sovereign straight which of
course it is
but how far historically you want to go
back you know how far do we go back
well that's always the argument though
and i and that they like to make um
any of the any any of these sort of
dictators i like to make when they
invade someone is like well a hundred
years ago it was like this so we're
gonna go in now and take it back like
hey man it's not 100 years ago we're now
and now
ukraine is a a sovereign nation with
people and families that are running
their own system you don't just go in
there and take their stuff because even
20 30 whatever old soviet union you know
how many years ago a few decades ago it
was different back then like you know
that's like your girlfriend breaks up
with you and remarries and you kick the
door in and you grab her and take her
back because 20 10 years ago we were in
a relationship you're coming with me you
know like it's like
that's not reality or where we're at now
but we know that but that's that's the
argument they like to present but paul
we have to look at this in a context as
well i mean my house is my house is
older than your entire country i'm not
being funny it was built in 1500.
you know don't get me wrong you know
it's my grandma older than america but
you know from his context russia is
foundational he goes back and back and
back there's a huge amount of his
history there and of course he sees the
imbalance he sees the naivety of america
and i'm not saying that at all don't get
wrong but he looks it very differently
than how we look at it and of course
yeah
it's it's just i think i think if we
were in his position we'd be looking at
it going what's going wrong here you can
literally see i think he did um a
conference with the oligarchs didn't he
after this and you could see it sitting
there and every other conference i
believe after that his voice wasn't used
it was a it was a narrator but that
particular one you can find it the
conference with the oligarchs post the
the invasion he sat there and his voice
was fragile and he realized i think he
pushed the bad position he just crashed
the economy 30 and this dude's sitting
next to people where he realizes all of
a sudden he's not the biggest dog in the
pound anymore there's people there that
can kill him like there are literally
very wealthy people and he's just
destroyed their hereditary wealth it's
like this is familial wealth you got rid
of now and they have to rebuild this and
they're looking at him you see the
stairs they're like what did you do that
for
like what was that about and of course
they know it's about ego and everything
else and as far as they can just want to
make sure their wife gets down to
croatia for a holiday and she's giving
him stick now it's um
it's a very difficult thing but
you know oh no yeah you're well and
that's you make a great point there tim
is that there we're dealing with
fundamentally different ways of looking
at the world here and that's something
to always keep in mind and try to try to
see it from the other person's
perspective
so that we can
figure out the best strategy if we're in
a position i'm not positioned to figure
out anything other than my what i'm
going to do this afternoon but if i were
in that position i want to know
that perspective and sometimes i think
there's a lack of that um we see it in
things like well afghanistan is a great
example
the people of afghanistan and that
leadership
think
different and we're still human beings
we're more alike than we are different
but there are certain fundamental ways
of thinking and ideology that
makes us different and how they approach
a problem and so we have to understand
that in order to understand okay why
what are his motivations why is he doing
this and then well how can we solve this
without
using ukraine as a place to stack bodies
you know what i mean how can we do this
in a way that
we can sort of you know
everybody kind of gets some sort of win
out of it or feels like they are at
least um
again without running a proxy war of
insurgents out of ukraine for the next
20 years or whatever and so yeah and so
that's that's the thing it's really
important to to ask ourselves these
questions what are these different
individuals thinking not just what
they're saying to try to convince the
public well how do they view the world
you know what i mean hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you